auch in Bewerbungsverfahren hält
künstliche Intelligenz Einzug für
Arbeitgeber eine mögliche
Arbeitserleichterung der große Vorteil
ist eben dass er uns bei gerade einer
Vielzahl von Bewerbung viel
administrative Zeit und Arbeit abnimmt
aus Arbeitnehmersicht gibt es an solch
einem ki-einsatz aber auch Zweifel
möchte ich dass quasi eine Maschine mich
beobachtet bei solchen Sachen und dann
am Ende da Parameter beispielsweise
ermittelt die ich gar nicht mehr nach
vollziehen kann welchen Einfluss hat
künstliche Intelligenz für
Bewerbungsverfahren und können auch
Arbeitnehmer KI gewinnbringend für sich
einsetzen zum Einsatz künstlicher
Intelligenz bei einem
Bewerbungsschreiben machen wir ein
Experiment zusammen mit Marie die gerade
eine Stelle sucht derzeit bewerbe ich
mich für Stellen im IT support und ich
habe mich sonst immer eigentlich auf
Stellen beworben ind dem ich ganz normal
alles selber geschrieben habe mir Text
überlegt habe Freunde gefragt habe hey
passt das so kann ich das so schreiben
oder auch
nicht kann eine KI Marie bei den
Bewerbungsschreiben helfen macht ihr
Einsatz am Ende einen Unterschied aus
das wollen wir herausfinden auf
Jobportalen im Internet hat Marie fünf
Stellen gefunden die für Sie in Frage
kommen jetzt geht es an die
Bewerbungsschreiben ich musste erstmal
ein komplettes Anschreiben erstellen
habe ich sehr lange gebraucht so 30
Minuten ungefähr und dann einfach noch
mal ein paar rechtschreibfeder
regieren um herauszufinden ob der
Einsatz von KI die Chancen auf einen
neuen Job steigert hat Marie eine zweite
Bewerbung vorbereitet unter dem Namen
Luise Müller wird sie sich noch einmal
auf alle fünf Stellen bewerben
Lebenslauf und Qualifikationen sind
identisch das Anschreiben ist diesmal
nicht von
ihr ich lass mir gerade mit Hilfe einer
künstlichen Intelligenz eine Bewerbung
schreiben und gibt dem jetzt einfach so
ein paar Keywords was quasi in der
Ausschreibung der jobausschreibung drin
standen und dann hat er mir innerhalb
von paar Sekunden wirklich fast gute
Bewerbung
geschrieben am Ende befinden sich in
beiden Anschreiben etwa gleich viele
Keywords in der KI generierten Version
ergänzt Marie noch persönliche Daten
anschließend schickt sie fünf
Bewerbungen mit selbstverfassten
anschreiben und fünf mit dem
Bewerbungstext der KI
ab während wir auf die Reaktion der
Unternehmen warten wollen wir wissen wie
setzen Arbeitgeber KI in
Bewerbungsverfahren ein das fragen wir
etliche große Unternehmen in Deutschland
lange Zeit will sich niemand dazu äußern
schließlich finden wir in Köln ein
Unternehmen das bereit ist uns zu zeigen
wie Bewerbungen bei ihnen bearbeitet
werden das deutsche techunternehmen
Trusted Shops prüft die Sicherheit von
onlinehops und vergibt dafür ein
Gütesiegel das Unternehmen beschäftigt
rund 800 Menschen und sucht ständig neue
Mitarbeit Bewerbungen werden mit einer
speziellen Software gefiltert einem
sogenannten applicant tracking system
kurz
ATS Ricardo Greco leitet die
Personalabteilung bei Trusted Shops und
weiß wie die ATS Software
arbeitet das hier verwendete System
erkennt ob in einem Bewerbungsschreiben
Schlüsselworte aus der Ausschreibung
genannt werden oder nicht werden viele
Schlüsselworte genannt kommt der
Bewerber in die nächste Runde fehlen zu
viele Keywords gibt es eine Abs
bei den Keywords ist es wichtig wenn man
sich bewirbt dass man die
stellenauschreibung ganz aufmerksam
liest und eben schaut welche
Anforderungen werden dort formuliert so
und da nutzen sowohl die Maschinen als
auch die Menschen diese Keywords als
eine Filterfunktion sein Mitarbeiter
Alexandro Kanu hat täglich Bewerbungen
auf dem Tisch wie ihm die ATS Software
dabei hilft verdeutlicht er an einem
Beispiel im Falle dessen dass wir jetzt
nach Deutschkenntnissen gefragt hätten
weil das unabdingbar für die Stelle ist
und die Person verfügt über keine
Deutschkenntnisse kann das System das
automatisch rausfiltern und sagen da
fehlt schon etwas von den fachlichen
Anforderungen die Person wird
automatisch in den absageordner
geschoben und eben auch automatisch mit
der E-Mail über den Absagegrund
informiert die Entscheidung Bewerbern
abzusagen überlässt trusted Jobs aber
nicht immer alleine dem ATS die
Personalabteilung sichtet die meisten
Bewerbungen noch einmal Quereinsteiger
würden uns verloren gehen und die können
wir dann wenn wir da händisch noch mal
reingucken entsprechend anderen Position
zuordnen bedeutet konkret wir nutzen
diese Elemente aber wir haben noch kein
hundertprozentiges vertrauen dass die
auch zu 100% zuverlässig sind noch einen
Schritt weiter geht in Berlin das
Unternehmen phenen people die Firma hat
die ATS Software weiterentwickelt und um
ki-elemente ergänzt Sebastian hust
berätt Unternehmen beim Einsatz dieser
ergänzenden KI Bausteine er weiß das
Interesse der Personalabteilung daran
ist groß auch in mehreren daxunternehmen
nehmen denn der ergänzende KI Baustein
kann nicht nur Filtern wie ein ATS die
KI kann Bewertungen vornehmen aus
Parametern wie Berufserfahrung aktueller
Position und Qualifikation berechnet die
KI einen Wert A B oder C die KI zeigt
mir für welche Stellen ist jetzt die
Passgenauigkeit auf dem Papier zumindest
am größten und deswegen haben wir drei
Kategorien A B und C um relativ schnell
zu signalisieren wer passt nahezu
perfekt und wer ist wahrscheinlich gar
nicht so passend weil er oder sie nicht
die richtigen Skills mitbringt diese KI
kann eine Gesamtbewertung von Bewerbern
vornehmen damit gab es im
Bewerbungsverfahren auch schon schlechte
Erfahrungen das weiß Alis krittel er ist
Geschäftsführer des artificial
intelligence Center in Hamburg hier
beschäftigen sich Experten aus
Wirtschaft Wissenschaft und Gesellschaft
mit dem Einsatz von KI als
Negativbeispiel für den ki-einsatz in
Bewerbungen nennt man hier den
versandriesen amerson der hat 2018 in
den USA zur Auswahl von Bewerbern KI
eingesetzt bei der Programmierung aber
passierte ein Fehler die KI war mit
Daten von überwiegend männlichen
Bewerbern trainiert worden das heißt die
hat ganz klar dann Männer
quasi bevorzugt in dieser Suche bei
diesen unterschiedlichen Schritten und
Frauen eben entsprechend benachteiligt
weil man einfach von der
Wahrscheinlichkeit her gesagt hat dass
ein männlich Technik affiner Bewerber
passend ist sozusagen deutlich
höherbwertet hat das war ein typischer
Fall einer diskriminierenden KI als
azon den Fehler bemerkt stoppt das
Unternehmen den Einsatz von KI im
bewerberprozess also sie haben
tatsächlich die Fehler eingestanden
haben gesagt okay wir werden diese
Modelle nicht verwenden sind also ganz
klar zurückgerudert und letztendlich den
ganzen Prozess noch mal überdacht wo man
KI einsetzt wie man KI einsetzt in
Deutschland sorgt man sich beim kiinsatz
in bewerbungs Prozessen offenbar weniger
um mögliche Diskriminierungen als um die
Gefahr von
Datenschutzverstößen dies betont das
Bundesministerium für Arbeit und
Soziales in Zusammenhang mit einem
Gesetzentwurf zur Regulierung von KI in
der Arbeitswelt jedenfalls ganz
besonders mit dem Beschäftigten
Datenschutzgesetz wird es erstmals
gesetzliche klare Regelungen für die
Verarbeitung von Beschäftigten Daten
sowohl im Bewerbungsprozess als auch im
Beschäftigungsverhältnis selbst geben
ind dem klar ist welche Daten
verarbeitet werden können
zurück zu Marie und unserem
bewerbungsexperiment nach vier Wochen
liegen die Antworten auf die
Bewerbungsschreiben vor mit ihrem
selbstverfassten Anschreiben wurde sie
zu vier Vorstellungsgesprächen
eingeladen und erhielt eine Absage mit
dem KI generierten
bewerbungsschreibenhelt sie drei
Einladungen eine Absage und einmal keine
Antwort ich fand die Stichprobe gut um
herauszufinden dass KI halt doch noch
nicht so ausgereift ist dass man da
jetzt wirklich perfekte Bewerbung
mitchreiben kann allerdings hat mich es
auch war der anderen Seite sehr
überrascht wie gut die KI schon war dass
ich wirklich auch einige Einladung hatte
mit einer Bewerbung wo ich 2 D Minuten
an Zeit investiert habe und das ist
natürlich schon super aber ob bei der
Bewerbung nun KI zum Einsatz kommt oder
nicht wichtig ist in jedem Fall dass im
Anschreiben möglichst viele
Schlüsselworte aus der Stellenanzeige
vorkommen denn darauf achten die meisten
Unternehmen ganz besonders und zwar
unabhängig davon ob sie ihrerseits bei
der Bewerberauswahl KI einsetzen oder
nicht